we're in the middle of the worst Ebola
outbreak in history it's a global health
emergency but how did it get this far
I'm Dina and here's what you need to
know about what it's going to take to
stop Ebola Ebola is a virus usually
found in tropical regions it was first
discovered in 1976 near the Ebola River
in the Democratic Republic of Congo
scientists think it comes from fruit
bats and among people it spread through
contact with bodily fluids most Ebola
patients died and there is no cure the
current outbreak is the largest ever and
the first in West Africa it began in
Guinea in March and is spreading fast
and because Ebola is new to the region
there's a lot of misinformation out
there that's delaying treatment and
giving the disease more time to spread
and unlike before this outbreak is
affecting densely populated urban areas
so if there's no cure what's it going to
take to contain this epidemic a lot of
help from the rest of the world and
finally that's starting to happen with
3000 US soldiers building medical
centers and 165 Cuban doctors and a
Chinese lab team among those will be
helping a huge reason the outbreak
spread is poor medical infrastructure
the good news a lot of it can be
improved here's how by getting those
desperately needed medical workers on
the ground properly isolating and
treating infected patients and
protecting those most at risk the health
workers family members and mourners that
involves distributed sanitation kids
encouraging people to wash with soap and
quickly burying infected corpses
appropriately but experts say they've
never had to deal with something on this
scale and the UN says much more as
needed 1 billion dollars worth of aid to
be exact do you think governments are
doing enough to stop Ebola before it
spreads to other parts of the world let
us know
want more download the aj+ mobile app
and join the conversation available in
your app store now